you ready hate in Hayden's ready teemo's
ready let's go my no no what's up
believe nation happy weekend we are
vlogging this weekend we got pain in
here we've got Nina and Timo here and
today I'm taking my car van salsa team
to go snow tubing hey we're taking you
guys on a journey with us
[Music]
so once a quarter we try to do something
with the team just something fun
something not you know tedious related
family bonding time and today we decided
that we're gonna take everybody's snow
tubing so we've got I don't know 20
people or so tell me but before that we
have to go do our dance practice so get
some coffee get some food practice of
dancing we're waiting for TBS elevator
nina is carrying her jacket and Timo
Hayden is carrying a big huge bucket of
activities to do during dance class and
I'm carrying the hearts and minds of a
nation I don't think they're buying
[Music]
so one thing I didn't mention was I do
the group we have this sign Employment
Practice they say because I wanted my
instructors to have an opportunity to
get better so they do a lot of teaching
and they do a lot of well there's a lot
of teachers in a week we wanted to wait
them to get better as dancers and so I
hired Elton and marina are awesome
choreographers to come in and give the
instructors something to work on so we
have our Saturday morning practice every
week to work on the performance work on
competition and allow the instructors to
get better as dancers not just as
instructors as well so that's what we do
every week professional development for
the team concept learning and growing
and then every quarter we do something
fun like so to me you ready hatin
Haydn's ready teemo's ready let's go
teemo's getting his last walk
we'd like bringing with TDS but he's not
allowed to come snow tubing so he gets
his last walk before we go come on Timo
do your business do your business Timo
he's he's not doing a business nina's
bean is not happy
[Music]
there it is
that top that's the hill there's the
hill we're gonna go down there I'm
excited we made it
winter geared up ready to hit the slopes
Lina
looking sexy as ever Hayden rocking the
blue let's get on the hill let's go find
the team we got our team what's up we
got the team where's everybody else
Fernando mr. bachata you're gonna have a
good cycle maker buddy good let's send
you you might remember him from the
little man video yeah although I think
we blank out your face
alex is working hard
rah-rah stuff out like so that hit with
Brock in the Hat now he's now he's
putting it down now he's going garyvee
style putting it down but it's it's
still raw stuff Alex Nina's organizing
here's the crew led by the troublemaker
let's see some moose let's see it snow
praying for chata
snow chatter Wow what do you think Alex
thank you all right yeah
[Music]
show us how it's done Alex show us how
it's done just like that first line
first time's a charm job Alex thank you
you don't want to wear your gloves to
warm your sweating we'll wait till we
get on the hill you get some you get
some speed getting picked up here team
TDS let's hit some slopes safety take
you first
Alex will not be sued for this let's see
let's go let's go red
alex is wearing jeans and there's a ton
of water in his snowsuit oh this is
awesome
I am excited you're scared you'll be
fine you've done this
it's okay you'll be fine you got this
you're Carmichael
[Music]
it's more scary going up than down all
right well then it'll be easy going down
I like to snapchatting follow Alex on
snapchat hey guys we are gonna be snow
tubing for the first time I'm excited
got yarek right in the back now whoa
it's gonna be legendary
there goes TDS team number one see you
where'd they go there they go there they
go scared we're gonna do okay though we
got this we got this let's go let's hope
we live
[Music]
hi-five mr. boom good job alright let's
do it again that was a ton of fun we got
some good speed hey who wants to go
again let's do it again
alright time for round two let's do it
all right Nina's coming with us this
time I got Nina's feet in my face here
okay enjoy that foot Nina don't don't
rip off my shoe Nina is Nina screamer
Nina's a screamer
[Music]
why go backwards
[Music]
hater this Mickey Nina work you want to
pull me to come on the night you're
strong you need to balance out the must
on the left side
all right back in line round three what
are we doing this time Nina four people
okay you're in charge of recruiting our
teammate and Afghan creeper you have to
convince people to join our team you're
in charge of recruitment
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was the best that was the first
time I didn't get to go backwards and I
loved it they even wanted to increase
the number every time we went so I
always got to find a fifth person oh
we're going solo okay we can go solo out
there but you got to find somebody
recruit somebody onto the team all right
I like it what do you think Nina Nina's
happy Thank You Nina for setting this up
Nina organized all of this got 20 people
to show up found the place dealt with
all the maybes and the I don't knows and
the follow-up in the directions and five
to Pierre we are 250 Thank You Nina we
love you wakes and Hayden is wait am i
pulling you I don't know about that I
don't know that I signed up for that why
is my tube so heavy now and I don't
pretty sure did not sign up for this
maybe I'll sit in yours and then Nina
can pull me and then I can pull you what
do you think just set up a train Nina
huh all right we got our fifth person
the heat
we're doing five we're going five let's
see how far we go there we go
[Music]
you want to go by yourself
alright you can ask for a little spin
but guys for a lot of spin you're easy
to spin because you're so light okay
round five I'm not sure what we're doing
this although couples will figure it out
Hayden's going solo doing a spin it's
gonna be exciting
get ready to hand in little spin little
spin little spin you get a scream baby
hold on your hat looks like it's gonna
fall off
alright have fun
[Music]
all right one more round maybe our last
one we'll see running short on time
we're gonna have some follow-up we can
[Music]
Haven that's the last you run solo you
okay yeah fine that's how you spin on
that last one I like it we're gonna take
a good picture and then go get some food
yard yard is leaving us so after the
picture he's got a hot date yeah I've
got a hot date so he's leaving us but
otherwise everybody else is sticking
around with this Fernando's idea
something tells me this is Fernando's
idea
Oh Alex's idea all right team team TDS
there it is look at that that's the view
right there Nando right Alex you're on
[Music]
now Nina has the amazing job of finding
food that 20 people are gonna enjoy
eating she's ordering 10 large fries and
18 cheeseburgers so we're doing okay see
how the bacon alex is making it rain
french fries the tds tables all quiet
now burgers and fries bound
good job nina feeding the team alex is
making chicken tonight like chicken
tonight we feel like you're a chef
because this is what a chef does well
like like when they're baking stuff
right because you're baking right now
you know the thing with that with the
thing that's the thing the thing yeah I
think you're baking
I think this qualifies as baking Payton
has his burger done look at that every
time we do one of these helper outings
Alex does a speech so I'm gonna film it
come on out let's give us the speech
[Music]
I think it's time for Alex's speech I
think it's time it's very stable second
we're all we're all very excited what
you're going to do what's it gonna do
how are we going to be moved and
remember this day forever based off of
the speech that's about to come from
this man see my eyes amount of
confidence and panic and passion I have
all right here here come's beautiful we
believe in you Alex
we believe in you know what I just want
to say I want to say how grateful I am
that everyone is ADA here and all the
people that you know that couldn't make
it I don't know all the other helpers
they're giving this but we're gonna have
a lot of socials coming our way I think
that the biggest thing in the last year
or two since I've joined that I've seen
is not only like the variety of new
people that are coming through and the
differences and the passions that
they're bringing in but more important
is how TDS is changing even the smallest
things even things like name tags or
whatever what makes I think our school
is that we're not always happy just
having things the same way that it's
always been done even today right having
people bring in their family right
that's never been done but like what
does family mean and what I'm really
excited is to have everyone continue to
stay with us as we really define more
what family means as a culture and bring
that out in all the classes and bring
that off and all the fun like all the
things I'm seeing for now to do that I'm
picking up the selfies and stuff and
like growing together and teaching each
other and all the voices of that yeah
but it's important for us in our school
we're more encouragers than we are
critics and I think that that's what
makes everyone who has no confidence
low self-esteem just from zero we make
them into heroes and I think that as
long as we do that and however we evolve
even we're more encouraging than critics
I think that everyone's going to feel
like they're part of the family and so I
just want to say how grateful I am to
you as myself at least as I'm learning
to navigate all this and try to make it
better for all of you guys and try to
make it more fun I love the fact that
we're coming together we're eating
together and we're continuing to do that
so as a develop our family and it's
going to be more than a year nor in two
years let's continue to be four meals
and just share that look and be more two
cards book toast all right the Sun is
setting
we had our awesome meal we had a good
time thank you for joining us on this
hopefully you had some fun watching too
and I think it's important that you
invest back into your team we started
this morning doing the professional
development stopped learning how to
dance Nina just wants to get in and then
tonight just recognizing the team and
doing some fun stuff just to say thank
you and thank you to this lady
Nina Carmichael for organizing
everything
in other words organizing everything
following up with everybody making sure
we all got our passes all got our food
all had a good time because this woman
here worked so hard one of the many
reasons why I love her if you love Nina
leave a comment below to thank you guys
for watching hopefully you have an
amazing weekend
[Music]